bien en este vídeo vamos a hablar de la
multiplicación de mono mios déjame
escribir aquí mono dios
y bueno un monoblock es aquel que tiene
solamente un término déjame darte un
ejemplo 4x cuadrada éste es un binomio y
porque bueno porque mono mono significa
1 y entonces tenemos un solo término
hace referencia al número de términos
entonces 4 x cuadrada es solo un término
y vamos a estar trabajando con cosas
como esta pero por ejemplo que hay de 4x
cuadrada 4x cuadrada más 5 x cuántos
términos hay aquí bueno 4 x cuadrada es
un término y 5x es otro término por lo
tanto este no es un mono de hecho esto
es lo que se conoce como un binomio
y es un binomio porque tiene dos
términos este prefijo mil significados
como las bicicletas por ejemplo que
tienen dos ruedas y etcétera y tal vez
en un futuro trabajaremos los binomios
pero por ahora sólo vamos a trabajar con
los monos y vamos a trabajar con la
multiplicación de los mono mios así que
qué te parece si trabajamos con un
ejemplo me voy a tomar el siguiente
ejemplo se me ocurre pensar en 5x esto
elevado al cuadrado por 4x elevado a la
sexta potencia cuántos esto bueno yo
espero que al final de este vídeo te sea
muy claro multiplicar monómeros como
estos y justo ahorita te voy a dar la
respuesta para que después vayamos a
analizar poco a poco cómo llegamos a
esta respuesta la respuesta de
multiplicar este mono mió por este mono
mío es lo mismo que 20
es elevado a la potencia 8 así que
seguramente por aquí vas a encontrar un
patrón como lo hicimos para que este 5
de aquí y este 4 de aquí meten este 20
de aquí y como le hicimos para que este
2 de till 16 de aquí meten este 8 de
aquí bueno antes de que te dé esa
respuesta que te parece si recordamos
algunas propiedades de los exponentes y
de hecho voy a pensar en esta propiedad
de los exponentes en esta propiedad en
específico que dice si tengo un 5
elevado al cuadrado y lo multiplicó por
5 elevado a la cuarta potencia bueno
esto va a ser lo mismo
cuántos esto bueno el resultado de esto
es 5 elevado a la sexta potencia si
recuerdas las leyes de los exponentes y
para eso estamos haciendo un pequeño
repaso lo que hacías es sumar los
exponentes
entonces me quedaría dos más cuatro esas
seis
5 al cuadrado por 5 a la cuarta potencia
es lo mismo que 5 a la sexta potencia y
que hay de esto de 3 elevado a la cuarta
potencia por 3 elevado a la quinta
potencia bueno de nuevo la base se
mantiene que es 3 y los exponentes los
sumamos 4 5 es lo mismo que 9 y bueno ya
que recordamos esto qué te parece si
ahora hacemos una multiplicación de un
mono mío por otro voy a empezar con este
4x que multiplica a x este va a ser
nuestra primera multiplicación de mono
mió por mono y bueno la única diferencia
entre esto y lo que estaba haciendo acá
arriba es que aquí tengo involucradas
variables así que podemos a pensar un
poco esto aquí tengo mi primer mono mío
y aquí tengo mi segundo mono mío y
observa qué bueno el segundo mono mío no
tiene ningún otro número justo aquí para
multiplicar con el 4 entonces
simplemente me va a quedar 4 y después
tengo un equis
x lo cual es x cuadrada recuerda si
tengo una variable y no tiene exponente
señalado entonces es equivalente a
pensar que esta variable tiene como
exponente 1 entonces aquí tengo como
exponente 1 aquí también tengo como
exponente 1 y me va a quedar que uno más
uno es lo mismo que dos y por eso
llegamos a 4x cuadrada justo como vimos
en los exponentes hace rato bueno qué te
parece si hacemos otro voy a pensar
ahora con este color en 4t esto que
multiplica a 3
bueno esto va a ser igual a si observas
primero lo que voy a hacer es
multiplicar los coeficientes 4 por 3
bueno eso es lo mismo que 12 4 por 13 12
y después voy a multiplicar las
variables de corte es lo mismo que te
cuadrada de cuadrada entonces mi
respuesta va a ser 12 t cuadrada creo
que ya estás viendo el patrón por aquí
así que vamos a hacer uno más que te
parece si nos tomamos a 4pm elevado a la
quinta potencia esto que multiplica a
5pm elevado al cubo a cuánto será igual
esto
y bueno primero lo que voy a hacer es
multiplicar los coeficientes este por
este y 4 por 5 es lo mismo que 20 y
después lo que voy a hacer es
multiplicar las variables p a la quinta
por p al cubo es lo mismo que p elevado
a la potencia
entonces multiplique 4 por 5 para
obtener 20 y después sume los exponentes
5 y 3 y así obtuve 8
ahora si realmente quiere saber de dónde
viene esto lo que podemos hacer es
tomarnos esta expresión de aquí y ahora
vamos a desglosar la 4 p a la quinta es
lo mismo que 4 que multiplica apm que
multiplica su vez apem que multiplica a
su vez ap que multiplica su vez ap que
multiplica a su vez ap tenemos aquí el
síncope es que multiplican a 4 ya esto
lo vamos a multiplicar por 5 que
multiplica a su vez ap que multiplican a
su vez ap y están que multiplican a su
vez ap tengo cinco por tres pes
ahora lo que voy a hacer es agrupar en
un mismo lado los números 4 y 5
entonces me va a quedar 4 por 5 y
después voy a agrupar todas las veces se
observa primero tengo 5 p es entonces
las voy a poner aquí p
por p por p por p por p
y después tengo otras tres por acá estas
otras tres entonces esto por p por p por
muy bien y entonces esto me va a quedar
4 por 5 es lo mismo que 20 y después
tengo p por pepe por pp por pp por p 8
veces
entonces me quedaría bien elevado a la
potencia por eso
así es como simplificamos toda esta
expresión loquísima de aquí en esta que
tengo aquí escribimos todo esto como
primero la multiplicación de dos
coeficientes y después una base y un
exponente y esto es lo hermoso de la
multiplicación de un mono mió por un
mono mió porque podemos escribir lo que
teníamos es decir una expresión
loquísima como ésta como 20 p elevado a
la 8 claro sabiendo esta expresión que
teníamos y usando las propiedades de los
exponentes y observa que esto a lo que
llegamos fue exactamente lo mismo que lo
que teníamos acá arriba muy bien así que
qué te parece si hacemos uno más
ahora voy a trabajar con el siguiente
ahora quiero hacer 5 en 5 james elevado
a la sexta potencia que multiplica a y
lo voy a poner entre paréntesis porque
voy a poner un signo negativo a menos 3
bien a la octava potencia bueno esto va
a ser igual a cuánto bueno pues de nuevo
vamos a multiplicar 5 por menos 3 lo
cual me da menos 15 y vamos a sumar las
potencias y tengo ya la sexta porque
adaptaba es lo mismo que ya elevado a la
6 más 8 14 de lujo entonces mi resultado
es menos 15 y elevado a la potencia 14
ok vamos a hacer uno más loco vamos a
divertirnos una vez más así que qué te
parece si ahora agarro menos 9
quinta por voy a poner paréntesis porque
tengo un signo negativo menos 3x y no sé
se me ocurre a las 107 a las 107 muy
bien ahora si multiplico estos dos que
me va a dar y estoy seguro que si te
hubiera enseñado esto antes de empezar
el vídeo dirías santo cielo no voy a
poder hacer esto estoy arruinado no hay
forma de resolverlo pero ahora ya sabes
que es tan simple como primero
multiplicar menos 9 por menos 3 lo cual
me va a dar 27 positivo observa menos x
menos me da más y 9 por 33 27 y después
me voy a tomar x elevado a la quinta
potencia por x elevado a la potencia 107
me va a dar x elevado a la potencia 102
no no no espera espera vamos a quitar
esto porque esto no está bien no es a
las 102 esto es un error
y vamos a poner la respuesta correcta la
respuesta correcta es x elevado a la 112
bien mi segunda oportunidad está bien y
entonces esta expresión loquísima que
nos daba miedo en un principio la cual
es una multiplicación de dos monómeros
aquí tengo el primero y aquí tengo el
segundo bueno ahora simplemente cuando
lo multiplicamos y lo simplificamos nos
da otro mundo gmio que es 27 x a la 112
muy bien ahora vamos a resolver un
último ejercicio y con eso vamos a
terminar este vídeo pero este ejercicio
tiene un pequeño problema a ver si lo
puedes ver en este ejercicio se lo di a
a un alumno y le pregunté cuánto es 5x
elevado a la tercera potencia
4x elevado a la sexta potencia y bueno
el alumno me dio una respuesta pero fue
una respuesta incorrecta él me dijo que
la respuesta de esto era lo mismo que 9
x a la 18 y esto está completamente mal
ahora lo que te pregunto es qué hizo mal
quiero que pienses porque esto está mal
y sobre todo pensando en lo que acabamos
de aprender en este vídeo cómo hizo para
que este 5 de aquí y este 4 de aquí les
dieran este 9 de aquí y cómo le hizo
para que este 3 de aquí y este 6 de aquí
le dieran este 18 de aquí y ya que se
pase eso ahora lo que quiero que me
digas es que debió de haber hecho bueno
este fue el vídeo de cómo multiplicar un
mono mió por un mono yo espero que te
haya gustado